kit vous connais cette chanson laver la
main qui d'entre vous la connais pas
levé la main les premiers explique aux
autres les grandi avec ses génériques
qui annonçait les émissions de doha les
radis de gros et de paix dit aujourd'hui
j'aimerais partager avec vous l'idée
suivante oser être chaque c'est la
relation avec les collaborateurs qui
permet d'écrire la beauté pur produit du
beau service dans ma société que j'ai
créée tout chômé aux et d'engager ses
collaborateurs
je vais vous détailler mon idée entre en
partie les verts ils misent en pâté et
des illustrations les faits en 2012 un
rapport a été fait sur les attentes et
des châles temps des entreprises
ce rapport indique que les chaps attente
les collaborateurs services investissent
dans notre travail qui sont efficients
et efficaces et qui leur a même plus de
solutions que de problèmes mais de
chiffrement est né il ya seulement 0 25%
des chefs qui s'attendent que les
collaborateurs
suivent leurs directives il ya seulement
10 % qui s'invente qu'elle est
collaborateur respecte les autorités à
sa méthode
observons les clones de clown peut nous
inspirer les relations plus simple et
plus simple saine et nous ramène à
l'essence de la relation du monde le
clown ils cessèrent justement de ce
rapport here are chic entre chefs et
collaborateurs pour avec ça a évité de
faire rire le public
les sketches de laura les radis sont
basés sur cette dynamique dans les
dirigent et l'autre sous 1,10 euro c'est
lui le chef c'est lui qui commande qui
donne les ordres
qui dit à l'autre ce qu'il faut faire et
il veille aussi au bien être de l'autre
lorraine le petit c'est lui le suiveur
c'est lui qui exécute c'est lui qui est
toujours dont le oui choque
il fait ce que l'autre mais dit il
admire son chef leur relation
pour l'illustrer imaginez-vous l'image
d'un iceberg
vous avez la petite partir au dessus ou
en dessous dessous de en dessous au
dessous de l'eau et la grande partie en
dessous l'apathie partir de présente le
contenu au niveau du contenu
ils sont pleins de disputes des encore
d'avis divergents
par contre au niveau la relation ils
sont toujours dans le mille
oui dans l'acceptation inconditionnelle
du rôle de l'autre ensemble ils
produisent un beau produit deux rives
oui maintenant ça en situation j'ai
besoin de quelqu'un oui ça vous pouvez
entendre comme un instant oui oui aller
avec ça ah oui vous pouvez n'intervient
au centre de ce joli des rouges que
tadic ce nous a posés ici je vais vous
montrer un exercice et après je vais
vous demander de l'exprimer donc d'abord
tous les deux on va se mettre d'accord
d'accord qui de nous deux et de chaque
et je vois dans son regard qu'elle me
dit cet ouvrage tant qu en tant que ça
moi je vais lui donner des ordres et on
entend plein suiveurs je vous demande
seulement drake sécurité je vous donne
de trois exemples voilà d'événements et
son et la main d'oeuvre est le bras
descendez de bras voilà c'est ça la
exercice et merci beaucoup pour l'avoir
démontré avec moi oui maintenant on va
prendre à aller manger au milieu voilà
s'il vous plaît mettez vous debout au
milieu seulement les venger au milieu
voilà mettez vous debout
voilà
je vais répéter les instructions du
tournez vous vers votre voisin donc en
principe j'ai dérangé sent bien quand
vous en avez à autrement vous allez
observer maintenant décider entre vos
deux qui échappe
allez
vallat et à trois c'est parti donner des
ordres à votre collaborateur qui lui va
exécuter toit de l'un de ces partis
et
oui très bien avait dit avant les autres
années de marasme social inventer encore
oui
encore ne ratez ce prix merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup
oui j'aurais bien aimé prendre ma
revanche
maintenant c'est facile d'être clair oui
quelques fois j'ai manqué de direction à
donner
oui un autre à l affiche ce que je
voulais annonce était quelquefois autre
chose que je m'imaginais moi oui pas
facile de suivre
ancien grand confort de suivre nous
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait à la place
de l'autre je vous donne quelques
illustrations sur justement ce rapport
jacques collaborateurs en 2002 j'étais
élève à l'école du cirque du luxembourg
notre président raphaël est venu me voir
j'ai vendu ton spectacle
quel spectacle donc pour moi il ya le
cerpi ethiopie qui vient et tu vas jouer
en avant programme spectacles
celui que tu vas créer comment savait-il
qu'au fond de moi j'avais envie de créer
un jour un spectable j'en avais jamais
fait il voyait plus grand que moi et
comme je respecte et son autorité et que
je voyais dans son idée c'était pour mon
bien et celui de l'école de cirque
j'ai suivi ses directives trois mois
plus tard j'ai joué mon premier
spectacle de cirque devant 800 personnes
qu'est-ce que ça t'inspire comme
hésitant dans ma vie personnelle ou
professionnelle à huit mois j'ai compris
que pour réaliser son rêve
le petit a besoin du grand pour l'aider
à se dépasser
si aussi l'histoire d'aurelio un autre
élève de l'école de cirque aurait dur
lui il était c'était un râleur avec son
chef toujours ils contestent et où il
n'était jamais quand on en a il faut
faire ça différemment mais on pouvait
mais non à voir aurelio suit un stage de
clown son rapport avec son chef a évolué
il a mis en place le riche en taurine
avant quand les chaplin manque quelque
chose dans nos élites michaud depuis le
chef il lui donne plus de
responsabilités ils écoutent plus
souvent ils n'ont plus souvent a besoin
de son avis et il a beaucoup plus de
plaisir à travailler avec lui et toi
comment vis-tu de l'entente avec à l
affiche à moi j'ai compris que le
collaborateur qui accepte et valorise
les chefs dans son rôle ils aident à
devenir un meilleur chef en 2006 j'ai
créé mon premier spectacle de clown un
duo clownesque basé sur sa dynamique
entre le gros et de petit c'est
l'histoire de deux pompiers qui doivent
recruter des jeunes alors il ya mon chef
qui me
je monte dans le rôle de billy de place
je suis pas pareil so amplement en
censeur par ascenseur sow ascenseur dans
perche et pose un jour ça change
mon chef me donne d abandonner
qu'est-ce que vous penserez d'un
chantage et on pourrait éventuellement
réfléchir à un saut si ça vous plaît un
ascenseur et pourquoi pas autre chose
j'étais complètement perdue je trouvais
plus le rythme du spectacle et des
spectacles il affûté après on en a
discuté
je demandais à marquer ce qui s'est
passé il ma vie mais écoute il ya mon
fils de trois ans qui était dans le
public et d'une non pas que je te donne
des ordres
ah oui qu'est ce que ça te dis moi j'ai
compris que le chef qui veut diriger
pour plaire mais il se trompe ce message
le chef doit diriger pour rentrer en
relation à pourrait traîner
et quand il est clair dans ses
directives quand il assume son rôle
il va aider les collaborateurs a aussi
trouvé s'envoler dans les spectacles du
gros et du petit les gens rient souvent
beaucoup plus tu te dis c'est lui qui
plus drôle qui prend les sympathies du
pays
alors le mot ça ne rend pas triste
mais d'un autre côté les huit aussi très
fier à ce qu'ils disent est tout seul il
ya des brèves et seulement relation avec
l'autre il tape produits respectifs
quand le grand et de banques on ne voit
que lui
alors que quand le crédit est devant on
va tous les dix ans du clown m'ont aidé
à assumer mon autorité
aujourd'hui je suis jeune j'ai engagé
une collaboratrice et je suis très fier
de notre relation de travail qui permet
de créer du bourg derrière la protection
la plus directe entre deux personnes moi
je dirige
elle exécute et quand ça ne marche pas
on rigole
bien